We're out here by the Computer History Museum
in Mountain View, California. The Google headquarters is
just around the corner. But before we start
to build our applications on the Google cloud platform,
let's look at the history of building server
side applications. Fifty years ago this is where
most server-side applications were born. On a physical
computer sitting under the desk in some office. Yeah,
seriously. A physical computer, you know, one that
you can touch and smell. And the generated
heat from the fan outlet, so you could
warm your feet, if the office was cold. Well,
it didn't take long until the server-side applications
grew bigger. And it was no longer possible
to run them on a computer like this.
So the pizza box computer was created because it
looked like a pizza box. And these were great
because you could stack them on top of each other
and on top of each other and on top of each other. And voila! The
computer rack had just been born. And the entire shebang was put in a dedicated
room called the data center, because all the fans made too much noise and stuff.
But it was no longer possible to warm
your feet against the fan outlet of course.